قال الموفد الامريكي لترسيم الحدود بين
لبنان واسرائيل اموس ستاين ان واشنطن تفضل
الحل الدبلوماسيه للازمه بين لبنان
واسرائيل وان هذا ما يريده الجانبان حسب
تعبيره واضاف اوكستين بعد لقائه رئيس
البرلمان اللبناني نبيه بري في بيروت انه
يامل في الوصول الى حل يسمح للشعبين
اللبناني والاسرائيلي بالعيش في
امان نحن بحاجه للوصول الى حل دبلوماسي
يسمح الشعب اللبناني بالعوده الى منازله
في جنوب لبنان والى حياته الطبيعيه كما
ينبغي ان يتمكن الشعب في اسرائيل من ان
يعود الى منازله وان يعيش بامان لقد اجريت
محادثات جيده هنا مع الحكومه وامل ان
نتمكن من المضي قدما للوصول الى حل يسمح
للشعب من الجهه اللبنانيه والجهه الاخرى
بالعيش في امان والتركيز على مستقبل افضل